I guess it starts right away.
I can check here.
Yeah,
it's life.
And that's that.
All right.
It looks like we're ready to go.
So welcome everybody.
Um,
let's see how the q and a and goes.
I've got a number of,
of uh,
the questions that people have already
submitted,
so I'll probably start with those.
And for those of you who are on the live
chat,
you can submit questions too and I'll,
I'll probably just move back and forth
between the ones that are pre submitted
in the ones that you guys are asking.
So,
and yes,
it will be uploaded later.
And uh,
I think youtube does that automatically.
Really good to see all of you,
um,
are people from all over the world here?
London and Vancouver.
And let's see,
where else are you guys from?
Okay,
well Toronto,
that's not quite as exciting since I
live here.
Quebec,
Calgary,
Edmonton,
Vienna.
Okay.
Boston,
Auckland,
New Zealand,
Montreal,
Texas.
Here we go.
Morocco,
Netherlands.
Yeah,
it's amazing that this can,
this can happen like that as far as I'm
concerned.
So it's going to take me just a bit to
get adapted to what I'm doing.
Okay.
First question,
what is your advice for finding a sane
sound therapist and do you think a
fruitful psychotherapeutic relationship
requires a therapist to have specific
temperamental compatibility or even
literacy and interests that align with
the patient?
Well,
I would say with regards to finding a
sane and sound therapists there some
practical things you can do.
Um,
I guess this is more relevant if you
live in North America and I'm not sure
exactly what the training requirements
are and other places in the world,
but your best bet I would say is to find
someone who's appropriately trained.
And I would regard someone who's
appropriately trained as a
psychotherapist to be someone who's,
I think you're safer if you go with
someone who's trained at one of the big
research schools and you have a
therapist who's well versed in
psychotherapeutic practice but who's
also sufficiently educated
scientifically to be able to understand
the scientific literature.
And you can be pretty certain of that if
you find a therapist who's got their
phd,
um,
rather than a psy d now,
not that there's anything necessarily
wrong with Saudis.
If they go,
Hey,
go received their phd from an American
Psychological Association approved,
um,
school of clinical and those schools
operate under what's called the bolder
model.
And the boulder model is promotes,
um,
what now what,
what's it called,
science,
science practitioner as,
as the optimal ideal combination for a
psychotherapist.
So someone who's trained
psychotherapeutic,
but also has research experience and can
understand the relevant scientific
literature as it pertains to,
to mental health.
So that would be the first thing.
The second thing I would say is,
um,
well I go to see yours,
a psychotherapist once and maybe go to
see a couple of them and find someone
that listens to you because the
psychotherapist shouldn't be someone who
solves your problems for you or offers
even really offers you advice.
Although sometimes that can be helpful.
Really what the psychotherapists should
do is be someone who can help you
understand what problem it is that
you're facing so that that can be
delineated properly to help you
articulate what it is that you want.
So what your vision of mental health
might be and what you'd like to attain
in psychotherapy,
and then who helps you strategize
towards that end.
And so you want someone who will really
listen to you that you feel comfortable
telling the truth too,
because that's also incredibly
important.
You have to,
you have to,
uh,
if you can't tell your psychotherapist
the truth,
then you're not going to get anywhere in
therapy because you won't be able to
actually outline the nature of your
fundamental problems.
So that's vital and go see someone and
see if you're happy with the way that
you're interacting with them.
That's the most relevant issue.
So
that's the first question.
Now the next one was,
do I think s fruitful psychotherapeutic
relationship requires the therapist to
have specific temperamental
compatibility or even literacy and
interests that align with the patient?
I think that
it's,
I think it's difficult to work with a
therapist who is less intelligent than
you are.
That's kind of a rough way of
conceptualizing it.
But a lot of what a therapist does is
help you strategize and the person has
to be able to think analytically and
probably at least to some degree to the
same with the same degree of complexity
that you're capable of.
Um,
it's not necessarily a good idea to be
able to out think your,
your therapist.
So
Dr. Peterson,
I heard you recently say that if a woman
doesn't want a baby by age 30 that
something is unhealthy.
I take no offense to that assertion.
Rather I am taking it very seriously.
I'm 34 years old in a longterm
relationship,
but don't feel desire to have children.
I always thought that I would one day,
but I'm getting older and that I'm
getting older and that day still hasn't
come.
I'm terrified of reasoning,
realizing too late that I should have
had a family.
But I'm also terrified of having them
and regretting it because it never truly
want it to be a mother.
I don't think I have any ideology at
play.
I'm not a feminist or anything like
that.
When you say something might be wrong or
unhealthy,
where might I look?
Any advice on how to make this change
but won't make this choice?
P S my boyfriend and I both had he
depaul mothers perhaps that is relevant.
Well it might be relevant given that you
saw fit to um,
included as a potential detail.
And one of the rules that I would
operate by as a psychotherapist is that
if a client is inclined to add a detail
to the
okay
to the formulation of a problem,
that the details are likely to be
relevant.
Um,
but I can't tell,
right?
Because of course I can't use it a rule
of thumb.
And so you might object,
well,
I shouldn't have used a rule of thumb to
say something like if a woman doesn't
want a baby by the age of 30,
that something is unhealthy.
Well,
are going to be exceptions to every
general rule.
But my attitude to this essentially is
that we have all come from an unbroken
string of 3.5 million years of
successful mothers.
And so the probability that that's going
to be part and parcel of the healthy
woman's desire and not only a woman,
no,
obviously men desire to have a family
too,
and often very intensely.
It's just that men have a much longer
time span over which to consider such
things.
So perhaps the chips aren't down so
rapidly and to the same degree for men.
Um,
I wouldn't be so bold as to say that
there's anything wrong with you,
the questionnaire specifically.
Um,
maybe you have the sort of temperament
that isn't particularly inclined towards
maternal behavior.
Uh,
that might be someone who's low in
agreeableness and well,
that would be the primary issue.
Um,
and so I wouldn't take my word for it,
that if you don't want to have a child
in your 30 that there is necessarily
something specifically wrong with you.
But I would say as a rule of thumb,
it's,
it's part of the normal panoply of human
desires and values.
And so if,
if,
if there's violent objection to having a
family or something like that,
then generally that seems to me to be
indicative of something that might be at
least worth looking into.
I'll try a live one here,
a live question.
Okay.
What do I think of Paul Joseph Watson
position that populism is the new punk
slash counterculture?
Oh,
that's a good question.
I actually happened to watch that video
a couple of days ago.
That's a good question.
I mean,
you see that,
you see,
I would say some indication of that on
Youtube,
although it's not easy to get an
unbiased sample of what's going on on
Youtube because of course youtube tends
to present you with things that are akin
to the things that you're already
watching.
It does appear to me that the
conservative commentators on youtube are
playing somewhat of the same role that
the counter culture played,
let's call it more traditionally.
Even though that's a funny thing to say
about the counterculture.
What I'm wondering more is whether or
not,
not so much whether it's a
counterculture,
but if it's something that's more
specifically associated with a place
that men,
young men are finding their new
political voice online.
Uh,
part of the reason that I'm wondering
about that,
although there are a number of female
conservative commentators who also
become popular online is because many of
the commentators appear to be man and
many of the people who are following
them also appear to be men.
And so,
and it's not obvious to me that men,
it's easy now for men,
especially young men to have a political
voice on campus for example,
or perhaps even in public.
Um,
and so maybe they're turning to youtube
to,
to find these viewpoints that aren't
being district disseminated is widely in
the,
in the popular media.
So
was there ever a time when you saw a
therapist of some kind?
Well,
no,
actually I haven't ever seen a therapist
and,
and uh,
that might seem strange.
I suppose given that I am a
psychologist,
um,
I don't really like talking about my
problems with other people.
As it turns out,
I'd rather keep them to myself and,
um,
but,
but I would say having said that is that
I've read an awful lot of the writings
of the great clinical psychologists and
psychiatrists and I would say that I've
used them as psychotherapeutic aids.
And I think that that plays,
uh,
a very similar role that can play a very
similar role.
So,
okay.
We just had to update the link.
Um,
so,
okay.
So let's try another question here from,
from the prepared questions.
I tried to rank order these by the
number of people that
mmm.
Indicated an interest in them.
So
you emphasize the spoken truth and
negotiation as the alternative to war
and site Solzhenitsyn as a brilliant
documenter of the potential or
inevitable fallout of deceit.
But in soldiers nip since diagnosis of
the factors leading to the Gulag
archipelago,
he also included the failure of people
to take a violent stand to disrupt
tyranny.
And here's a quote
and how will we burned in the camps
later thinking,
what would things would be like if every
security operative when he went out at
night to make an arrest?
Had been uncertain whether he would
return alive and had to say goodbye to
his family or if during periods of mass
arrests,
as for example,
in Leningrad when they arrested a
quarter of the entire city,
people had not simply sat there in their
layers paling with terror at every bang
of the downstairs door and every step on
the staircase,
but at understood they had nothing left
to lose and then boldly set up in the
downstairs hall and ambush of half a
dozen people with axes,
hammers,
pokers,
or whatever else was at hand.
The organs would very quickly have
suffered a shortage of officers and
transport and notwithstanding all of
Stalins thirst,
the cursive machine would have ground to
a halt if if we didn't love freedom
enough and even the more we had no real
awareness of the situation,
we purely and simply deserved everything
that happened afterwards.
End of quote,
there appears to be a point where the
price of our sovereignty and liberty
must be paid with blood in addition to
the vulnerability required by the spoken
truth.
Here are my questions.
Do you agree that there is such a point
or to the weapons in power we possess
today make violence in,
in viable course of action?
Okay,
well I would say first of all,
part of what soldier nicheness talking
about actually is the right to self
defense and you have the right to self
defense and you have the right to use
whatever force is necessary and
reasonable when you're defending
yourself and you know,
in under the American constitution for
example,
it's predicated on the idea,
at least in part,
that you have not only the right,
but perhaps the moral obligation to
resist tyranny.
And so obviously,
so that that's a difference.
That's very different from using
violence for specifically political
ends.
It's art.
Do you have the right to defend yourself
against incursions into your own home or
into your own family?
And I think the answer to that is you do
part of the reason that it has
manifested itself,
so that being dangerous is the
appropriate response.
Now then you might say,
well how do you know how to calibrate
your,
your defensive response?
And I would say,
well,
we have some legal guidelines for that.
Uh,
that would be the guidelines governing,
governing self defense in general.
I guess maybe it's time for a more
aggressive response when you're prepared
to pay the price for that or aggressive
response.
Do you have to think it through?
But you certainly have the right to
protect yourself and your family and,
and your property from inappropriate
incursion by other individuals or by the
state.
Uh,
and without knowing the specifics of any
given circumstance that might call for
such a response.
It's difficult to be any more straight
forward about that.
But I don't,
I'm certainly wouldn't regard myself
precisely as a pacifist.
I don't,
I,
because I believe that there are,
there are,
it's reasonable to meet
well,
how would I say you have the right to
self defense.
That's as clearly as I can formulate it.
Can I ask your thoughts on Brexit?
Uh,
that's a,
that's a question coming from the live
chat.
Yes.
You can have my thoughts on brexit.
Tom.
The other day I was doing a lecture on
the,
on the stories in genesis and one of the
stories that I analyze briefly,
and this will be posted very soon,
is the story of the Tower of Babel.
And I've been very curious about that
story.
It comes after Noah's flood myth in
genesis and
it's very interesting story in what
happens is that human beings get
together and they decide to build a
massive building and the human beings
that are building that building all
speak in one voice and they have this
grand vision,
which you might regard as a utopian
vision,
which is what I think it is,
that they can build a building so high
that within it everyone will speak the
same language and it will reach all the
way to have it.
And so you could see it in some sense as
an attempt to usurp the transcendent.
Um,
I kind of read it as an EA,
an early precursor of the story that
Milton told him,
paradise lost,
where Satan,
who's God's highest avidly angel and
perhaps,
and who's Lucifer?
That the brightest light in the psychic
hierarchy you might say.
And,
and the spirit of untrammeled
rationality decides that he can wage war
in heaven and overcome God,
overcome the ultimate in the
transcendent value.
When I read that as a cautionary tale
about the pride that goes along with
intellectual presupposition in the same
pride that produced the totalitarian
states of the 20th century,
what happens with the Tower of Babel is
that human beings start to build this a
unitary homogenous structure who's
pentacle will reach into God's heaven.
He domain perhaps thereby taking the
place of the transcendent God gets wind
of that and goes to earth and takes the
people or,
or transforms the people who are,
who are building the building and who in
principle it would house into a polyglot
of people speaking different languages
and then scatters them all over the
world.
Well,
what I think that means is that if you
try to build a homogenous totalitarian
structure that you searched the
transcendent,
it will begin to badly fragment from
within.
And I think it's a warning against
gigantism.
And I think one of the things that's
happening in Europe is that we're seeing
the folly of the idea of too big to
fail.
What we're seeing instead is the
manifestation of so big it will
certainly fail and I think the reason
for that is that there has to be a
certain degree of homogeneity within
anything that can be categorized as an
organization.
If the degree of heterogeneity within
the organization becomes too extreme and
if the organization becomes too large,
then it's very difficult for people to
feel any affinity with it.
They're going to fragment back into
their subsidiary identity groups and
those might be national groups for
example,
which seems to be what happened,
what's happening in Europe and then the
whole thing is going to fall apart.
And I have some sympathy for that
because I think that it's necessary for
human beings at an individual level to
feel some sort of affinity for the power
structures that they find themselves in.
And maybe being one 300 Mil,
one 300000000th of an entity is to be
too much of a non entity to feel any
real affinity for that structure.
So that's part of what I think's
happening with regards to brexit.
So,
okay,
so let's see what happens here.
A little another.
Let's take another live question here
is remove the toxic people in your life.
Wholly.
Good advice.
Well,
no,
I wouldn't say it's wholly good advice
because no single piece of advice could
be considered as holy good,
except perhaps for tell the truth.
I think that one might be outside that
that rule of thumb,
it depends very much on what you mean by
toxic and also who's doing the judgment
with regards to toxicity.
My sense is that you should surround
yourself with people who genuinely want
the best for you or perhaps more
specifically,
genuinely want the best for the best
part of you.
And if you're,
if the people around you are not
supporting you in your endeavors and
they put you down and they punish you
for your virtues or even punish you too
intensely for your faults and failed to
reward you when you're doing what you
should be doing and fail to engage in
reciprocal interactions,
that there comes a point where you would
be better off finding someone who is
actually on your side.
And that can even be the case with
family members.
Although of course that's a very
difficult decision to make.
But sometimes people do have the
misfortune of being up with family
members who are so who are operating in
a manner that's so counterproductive to
their health that it's better for them
despite the pain to cease communication
with them.
And,
and sometimes paradoxically enough that
can also facilitate communication
because sometimes you have to draw a
line in the sand before people are
willing to undergo the serious self
consideration that print would proceed
any real transformation.
So,
but I would say even if even if you
don't like the idea of removing the
toxic people in your life,
you should certainly endeavor to
surround yourself with the sorts of
people that you would want to surround
someone that you regarded as your friend
or loved one.
So you need to,
you need to extend the same courtesy to
yourself,
especially to the part of yourself that
striving upward that you would to
someone that you cared for.
So,
okay,
what do I think of the phrase diversity
is our strength?
Well,
I think it's a slogan and the word
slogan is derived from the Welsh two
words slew ag,
H and Gerome,
and slew a Garam is the battle cry of
the dead.
So the problem with that sort of slogan
is that it replaces independent thought
and it's certainly possible that quote
diversity is a strength,
an end quote.
But the question is,
what the hell do you mean by diversity?
And if the idea is that diverse modes of
approaching situations,
nestle necessarily emerge because you've
gathered people together who were of
some,
who are different in their whatever
group identity marker happens to be the
privileged one at the moment,
to use the postmodernists language.
There's no indication whatsoever that
that's going to produce diversity of,
of strategic plan for example.
So it's,
it's an empty phrase and it's a
dangerous phrase because diversity can
be a weakness.
It's just as much as it can be,
uh,
can be a strength.
So,
you know,
I think it's all right.
It's a slogan and I don't like slogans
very much.
So
do you have any practical advice?
Okay.
It's still on.
It's just the cameras.
The camera turned off for some reason.
Do you have any practical advice?
It's still an audio.
Yeah.
Well we,
I have all this new technology here
guys.
And sorry about that.
It's still,
we're still working out the bugs.
I bought new cameras and new lighting
and all of that and um,
it does strange things that we don't
understand yet.
And so it looks like I'm back on.
So do you have any practical advice on
how I can improve my ability to
concentrate and pay attention to the
world around me?
Um,
well,
I have some practical advice without the
first piece of practical advice.
Often the devil's in the details,
you know,
but often some practical advice as well.
Regulate your,
regulate your habits.
Um,
try to get up at approximately the same
time each morning.
I would recommend that you get up
approximately when other people get up.
So that would be something in the
neighborhood of seven 30 or eight in the
morning or perhaps earlier,
perhaps a little bit later.
But you want to stabilize that because
your,
your circadian rhythms operate more,
uh,
what would you call it to fluidly and
your mood is likely to be regulated
better if there's islands of stability
in your daily routines.
Human beings like daily routines,
just like dogs,
like daily routines and so regulate your
sleep.
Um,
I would say when you get up in the
morning,
eat breakfast,
that's a really important thing to do.
I can't tell you how many people I've
treated in my clinical practice who's
proclivity for emotional instability and
depression,
anxiety,
general hopelessness,
um,
emotional pain and gloom and doom as
well as capacity to concentrate.
We're property regulated or inhibited or
produced by merely ensuring that they
ate a,
I would say a protein and fat rich
breakfast relatively soon after they
wake up.
And that's especially too if they're
stressed.
And as it turns out that if you stress
yourself after a fast,
which is of course what you've
undertaken,
if you haven't eaten since the night
before,
that your body produces enough insulin
to deplete your,
your,
your to deplete the sugar in your blood.
And then it's very difficult for you to
become regulated properly with regards
to your metabolism,
metabolism until you sleep again.
And so it can be regulating your sleep
and your breakfast.
Eating habits in particular can be a
very effective way of regulating your
mood and increasing your capacity to
concentrate.
The other thing I would say is that
spending some time scheduling your time
is also extraordinarily useful.
And so I can tell you a little bit about
about how to use schedule as
effectively.
So the first thing I would do is,
the first thing I would say is that you
should,
um,
you should,
you should develop a longterm plan.
You can use something like the future
authoring program,
which most of you are familiar with
because of course you would have got a
key to it.
Almost everyone as a consequence of
being a patron is you have to,
you have to set up your vision like
Japan,
no,
when he's looking at the Star before
Pinocchio's transformation takes place,
you have to set up your longterm vision
to have some vision of the good towards
which you're working and some vision
perhaps of the hell that you're
avoiding.
And then I would say once you set up
that vision so that you know how to
Orient Yourself,
then you should start designing your
days.
And you can do that very effectively
with a calendar like Google calendar.
And instead of many people say,
well I hate using a schedule and,
or I hate using a calendar.
And what I would say about that is,
is that if you hate using a schedule or
a calendar,
then you're probably using it wrong.
What you're doing is using the calendar
as an external tyrant that's telling you
what you should do if you were going to
be a conventionally good person each
day.
So you load yourself up with,
with arbitrary,
we'll say arbitrary responsibilities,
but that's not really how you should use
a schedule.
What you should use a schedule to do is
to design the day that you would most
like to have.
And obviously that's going to include
accepting some responsibility and
undertaking to make progress on those
things that you have to make progress
on,
to keep your life from collapsing into
chaos.
But it should also mean that you
schedule in activities that make you
actually want to have that day.
And so if you're using a schedule
properly that it can be your friend and
that can also be something that can
increase your capacity to concentrate.
And then I would say,
well,
if you're,
if you're very scattered,
then you can start to train yourself.
You might say,
well,
um,
I need to learn to read without
distraction.
So maybe what you do,
you say,
okay,
well for the next week I'm going to read
10 minutes a day and I'm going to try to
limit the distractions.
And if you're successful at that,
then you could try 12 minutes a day.
you could try 15 minutes a day.
And the trick is to set a goal for
yourself that is slightly beyond your
current level of performance,
enough to be challenging enough to be
worthwhile if you accomplished but not
so difficult that you're likely to fail.
And then practice incrementally day by
day trying to inculcate the habits that
you want to inculcate and assume that
it'll take you a number of months or
even a number of years in order to
become very fluent at the habit.
The important thing is to start
improving incrementally because
incremental improvement pays off like a
compound interest.
And so I would also say that the
trajectory that you're on is more
important than your starting point.
And that's also an extraordinarily
optimistic observation because it means
that direction is more important than
current position and enemy current
position matters obviously,
but it,
I don't think it does matter as much as
direction.
So if you want to learn to concentrate
more,
define what constitutes concentration,
break it into micro habits and then
start practicing instantiation of those
micro habits.
So
very good advice here.
Robbie Kelly says,
how do you eat an elephant?
You bite one chunk at a time.
Well that's exactly right.
And that's also the hallmark of behavior
therapy,
the issue.
So what a behavior therapist does and,
and I'm an admirer of behavior therapy,
although there's other psychotherapeutic
approaches that I also appreciate too to
a great degree for,
for more that are in some sense more
conceptually sophisticated.
But one of the things you do if you're a
behavior therapist is take the problem
at hand and decompose it into its micro
elements and then practice
implementation of the micro elements.
And that can be the integration of new
habits is already mentioned,
but that's also a great way of learning
to face the things that you're avoiding.
Learning to confront the things you're
avoiding that frightened you were,
it stopped you in your trucks.
So you know,
if you,
if you're scared of going to parties or
maybe scared of going out in public,
you can also always go to the nearest
bar for 10 minutes and sit there and,
and have a drink and then leave,
you know,
and then maybe expand that up to 12
minutes and then maybe dare at one of
the dare at one point when you grow up
to say hi to someone.
But again,
don't ever underestimate the utility of
incremental improvement.
You can get a tremendous distance by,
by engaging in incremental improvement.
So,
okay,
so let's see here.
Why did I know how to upload my talk at
Western?
University of that will be being
uploaded.
There's a couple of talks I did that
just aren't the people that were
preparing them just haven't got back to
me yet.
I have a podcast that went quite nicely
with a German interviewer that I'm going
to upload this weekend.
I thought it was,
I thought it was good.
So,
but the,
the western university talk will be
uploaded.
I also did a talk in Calgary recently,
which I talked about something new.
I talked about equity,
which,
which I believe is absolutely
catastrophic,
uh,
goal.
Let's say that's equality of outcome.
I think the reason that it's
catastrophic is because you can't have
equality of outcome because you can
fractionate the group differences
between people and an infinite number of
ways.
So even if you did manage to produce
equality of outcome by you know,
the two top contenders for,
for prime group identity right now,
which are race and gender being pushed
very hard by the left,
which I would say is something that's
very racist and very sexist.
Um,
you might be able to reach equality of
outcome across race and gender,
although you couldn't practically
speaking,
but let's say hypothetically you could,
well then you'd still have to start to
fragment race.
So what do you mean by race exactly?
Are you going to stick with the three?
Well you might describe them as
canonical racial differences negroid
caucasoid in Asian or are you going to
start to fragment Asians into their
various subtypes and exactly how are you
going to do that or no,
are you going to do the same thing with
black people or are you going to just
assume that they're all the same?
And how do you know when someone's black
and not just dark brown,
so to speak,
or medium or light brown.
And I'd also like to point out just in
case anyone hasn't noticed that people
aren't black and white,
they're actually Tan and Brown.
And so,
and I'm saying that because there aren't
clear distinctions between the racial
divides.
And so you have to fragment race and
then obviously you have to fragment
gender at least according to the gender
theorists.
And then you have other problems of
group identity.
Um,
do you ensure that people are equally
represented across levels of
attractiveness or height or extroversion
or introversion or emotional stability
or mental health or physical health or
age or?
Well,
as you get the picture,
I don't have to continue to repeat
myself.
There is a,
there is,
there are as many,
there are an infinite number of
canonical group identities and there's
no way of making a,
an objective hierarchy out of them in
terms of value.
And so you can't equate for equality of
outcome up across all potential category
schemes.
And so equality of outcome is a futile
endeavor.
All that it does is transfer the power
that the free market should.
Um,
essentially the free market as an
externalized computational machine
should be calculating for us,
even though it's an imperfect
calculation,
all it does is transfer the power of
that collective and impersonal decision
making into the hands of a coterie of
people who will abs.
Even if the initial people who have that
power don't misuse it,
the people who take their place will
certainly misuse it.
So anyways,
have Calgary,
I did a talk on equity and tried to
outline some of these things.
Trying to understand exactly what is
wrong with the idea of equality of
outcome.
Mean the historical data obviously
indicates that it's a catastrophic
doctrine,
but I think there are technical,
psychological,
computational and complexity related
reasons why the doctrine of equality of
outcome is,
is uh,
is,
is it's an impossible goal.
It cannot be achieved even in principle.
So.
All right,
let's see.
The thinking skeptic says,
I love you,
Dr [inaudible].
Well,
thank you very much.
Uh,
thinking skeptic.
Um,
it's conceivable that I love youtube,
but I don't know because I don't know,
but we'll assume that we can start from
that perspective anyways.
Thoughts on the use of amphetamine to
improve conscientiousness?
Um,
the longterm data on use of amphetamine
as a treatment for attention deficit
disorders suggest that there are no
positive medium to longterm benefits.
So I would say that if you're going to
take a data driven approach to that
issue,
that you would draw the conclusion that
it's not a,
a useful long term,
uh,
solution.
Um,
yeah,
I experienced tremendous abuse as a
child and it's led to me being a doormat
for abuse.
I seek out people who reject me and
reject people who seek me out.
How do I break this cycle?
Wow.
Well that's a really,
really hard question and the reason that
it's hard apart from the fact that your
situation is very complex is that the
devil's always in the details.
What I would recommend though is that if
you want to break that cycle,
the first thing you need to do is to
figure out what it is that you want.
You need to understand where it is that
you want to go in your life and you need
to understand what people would look
like if they were the kind of people
that you could surround yourself with to
facilitate that goal.
And so I would again recommend that you
do the future authoring program so that
you can get your goals in order and then
you need to start thinking through how
it is that you would like to be treated
and what your strategies would be.
Even in principle if you find yourself
not being treated that way and then you
have to start practicing that at the
level of micro routine.
So,
and I think one of the ways that you can
do that,
and this is something I often recommend
to agreeable people,
is that he will see that there are
people who treat you in a manner that
leads to the development of your
resentment,
feelings of resentment.
And now there's roughly two reasons why
you might feel resentful and one is that
your just windy and someone is calling
you on your misbehavior or you're
failing because you should be failing
and you're not.
Your character isn't well developed
enough to merely adjust to the error and
to fix yourself up.
And the other is that you're being
genuinely taken advantage of and that
you need to put a stop to it.
And the only way that you can really
figure that out is by thinking it
through or writing it down or perhaps by
talking to someone that,
that you,
that that cares for you in a positive
way.
Once you've done that and once you
realize that you're resentful because
you are being interfered with,
then it's incumbent on you to say
something so that it,
it comes to a stop and you'll have to
practice that it and you'll be bad at it
to begin with.
Now,
it might be that your interact with
someone and you don't realize until
hours later that you don't like the
interaction that you had something to
say.
You might have to sit at home and then
figure out what it is that you should
say should have said and then go back
and tell the person you're going to be
awkward and bad at it.
But it's a good start.
And maybe you need to write out why it
is that you shouldn't be allowing people
to mistreat you so that you replace your
habitual proclivity that was may be
instilled in you when you were a child
with a thought through and mature
philosophy of interpersonal
relationship.
That's it.
That's a reasonable start.
So is it safe to go into psychology in
university?
Definitely not.
It's not safe to study psychology.
Uh,
but that's not really the issue.
I think what you mean has is has
psychology been so corrupted by let's
say,
political correctness so that it's no
longer a reasonable pathway.
It's no,
no longer a reasonable discipline.
And I would say I don't think it's
corrupted to that degree.
And I would also say that one of the
things you need to understand if you are
going to university,
that is that fundamentally university is
a place where you educate yourself.
Now you can seek out people who have
knowledge and confer with them about
your own education,
but the primary responsibility has to
fall to you,
the libraries and [inaudible] full of
great books.
And you can find out what the great
books are in a relative,
in a relatively short order manner by
just by even just looking online.
And you can do a tremendous amount of
reading and a tremendous amount of
writing on your own.
And you can do that very effectively if
you also treat your university
experience with the same degree of,
uh,
well,
what would you call diligence that you
might,
that you might put towards a full time
job.
So you want to find the professors that
have something to say and select them
and you want to do the readings of the
great books and you want to learn to
write.
And if you do that,
then you'll receive an education.
And you can do that pretty much at any
university I would say.
So what music do I like?
I like a lot of different music.
I like a lot of different genres.
I listen to rock.
I'm a dinosaur.
So I listened to classic rock all often
from the 70s I'm,
you know,
I was wired up and imprinted on that
stuff.
But I listened to rock music from the
fifties through today.
I really liked the band arcade fire for
example,
a beach houses,
a new band.
I kind of liked them.
There's a band called Devotchka that I
think,
I think they're out of Seattle.
I think they're really good.
I love Tom Waits.
I like old country music,
the Western stuff from the forties
thirties forties and 50s.
I listened to jazz.
I like blues.
I listen to classical music.
Um,
so,
uh,
I think I mentioned Tom White's already,
who I think is an absolute genius,
so I don't remember who said it once,
but someone said there was only two
kinds of music,
good music and bad music.
And I really believe that's true.
And so I,
I've found what I regard as great music
in all sorts of genres.
Um,
I wouldn't say I'm a hip hop officio,
but there's some of it that I've learned
to like,
uh,
I really like m and m's rap.
God,
I think that's an absolutely remarkable
song.
He's unbelievably skilled in this
ability to annunciate and I think
there's high quality music being
produced across a wide range of genres.
I don't like pop,
generally speaking.
Um,
it all sounds like bad.
1970s disco to me and I didn't like bad,
1970s disco,
so,
so that's what I liked for music.
Um,
let's see,
what else have we got here?
What
do I think of the comments?
The role favorable to me on that recent
Hamilton article.
Hamilton's a city,
the city where mcmaster university is
being disappeared.
Um,
I don't know what to think of that.
You know,
my,
my gut instinct,
and I would use this as a good rule of
thumb,
is to assume ignorance or error or
stupidity before you assume malevolence.
And so you have to go through those
alternative explanations first.
I mean,
I don't know why the comments were
shutdown.
Um,
I,
it would be easy to assume the worst,
but there's no reason to do that.
You don't want to jump to the assumption
of the worst to begin with.
So I thought it was curious and so I
tweeted it and I do think it's curious
and I do think that the,
the,
the threat of invisible Internet
censorship is a real one because w we
are conversing increasingly in this
public artificial intelligence,
giant invisible corporation mediated
way.
And we don't know what the rules are and
we don't know who can make them.
And I think that that's something we're
really going to have to watch out for
you.
I think you can see that happening with
facebook and twitter and perhaps with
youtube,
although I think youtube still pretty
clean,
although you know,
I've seen people complaining that
they're losing subscribers and that and
that their content is being restricted.
You know,
the thing is the company is going gonna
make some mistakes there.
They're trying to do multiple things at
the same time.
And so like I said,
I would assume,
um,
error and ignorance and stupidity and
then malevolence in that order and you
know,
give,
give people who are trying to mediate
these new technologies a bit of a break,
but that's still,
you should be awake because there is
always the potential for new and
unforeseen threats to emerge to freedom
of speech when it's electronically
mediated.
So
how will rescuing my father from the
belly of the whale helped me with
regards to leftist ideology?
Well I hope it would help you with
regards to ideologies in general.
I mean,
it's a serious,
that's a very,
very serious question
to believe that rescuing your father
from the belly of the whale would
inoculate you against ideology is to
accept it particular interpretation of
what that story means.
Now,
my interpretation of that story is that
the whale,
the whale dragon is a symbol of the
predatory unknown.
So it's a symbol of the dangers that
lurk in the unknown.
And the idea that the father,
the dying father or the or the ghost
father or the deceased father is lying.
Somehow inert in that landscape means
that encountering chaos can help you
understand more clearly what the value
was in traditional order.
But it's not only traditional order
that,
that that is the domain say of the,
of the resurrecting farther.
It's partly the farther represents
partly the spirit of the social order
and partly the,
the,
the implicit logos that's characteristic
of the individual that acts to create
society across time.
Um,
if you identify with tradition as,
as,
as the foundation of being and you
understand what identifying with the
spirit that creates tradition means,
then that gives you a means of orienting
yourself.
That's far preferable to any pure
ideology,
whether it's hiding in the nationals
structures that the right promotes,
um,
which tend towards rigidity,
rigidity,
and hyper order or drowning in the chaos
that the left producers in their
attempts both to demolish order sort of
on the negative end and,
uh,
transmuted say on the positive end.
It's better to,
I think it's better to act your life out
as an individual,
to incorporate the traditions that your
society has have brought forward to you,
into your life.
So to,
to do what other people do and to do it
well,
to,
to grow up,
to move out of your house,
to adopt the responsibilities of a
family,
to learn how to be honest,
to take on the heavy load of helping to
reduce unnecessary suffering in the
world and to try to make something
productive and useful of yourself.
And that's a lot more interesting and
meaningful than trying to,
um,
manifest yourself as the incarnation of
a pathological ideology.
Oh,
okay.
What the hell is it doing?
Dying?
No,
I turned it back on.
You don't game,
you stopped recording too,
so,
so I'm,
I'm,
I looks like I'm back.
There's a lag on the q and a,
so it's,
it's somewhat difficult to d Sherman.
So the Shaman to what did the Sherman
and D Sherman?
Yeah.
Hi.
I'm
okay.
Somebody says that this is the fault of
postmodernist.
It's probably is,
it probably is.
I,
that would be my guest.
They're probably putting like some kind
of electronic bug in my camera.
I don't know why it's shutting off.
I'll sort that out later.
So Julian,
we need you,
I guess you heard that a,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
okay.
So,
oh,
I agree.
How,
don't yell at Julian.
I get you now.
I can't,
I have to yell at him.
He's my son.
I can yell at him.
He's my technical support actually.
He's really good at it then.
I hardly ever yell at them to rough life
for me though.
Okay.
Let's say here,
take another question from,
from,
so someone says,
what's up with the socks?
Yeah,
well I have,
I guess I need to dim.
I guess I need to indicate to the rest
of you just exactly what that means.
You see these are the socks that we're
talking about here.
Um,
my wife bought me some fancy socks.
My,
my wife bought me some fancy socks for
Christmas and so I guess she thought my
style needed upgrading.
I guess it was partly because I got
completely reward robe to here.
I guess that might be a word in the last
few months I lost,
I've lost a tremendous amount of weight
in the last year about 40 pounds.
And you know,
some of that might be due to social
justice warriors.
So although it's really not,
it's because I've transformed my diet.
I seem to have a variety of dietary
sensitivities that seem to be
contributing to,
uh,
to,
I've had a history of depression and
that looks like it might be associated
with diet.
And my daughter who's been very ill with
a variety of health problems,
including extraordinarily serious
arthritis.
She lost her ankle and her hip to
arthritis when she was 17.
She's figured out that a lot of her
autoimmune problems were associated with
severe dietary,
uh,
sensitivity.
And we share some symptom overlap.
So I've had some autoimmune illness
problems.
And so she went on a very restrictive
diet,
which was basically only chicken and
vegetables and it,
it stopped the vast majority of her
symptoms,
including extreme fatigue and depression
and the arthritis itself.
And it had quite a market impact on her
to the point where she could stop taking
antidepressants.
And so about a year and half ago,
she convinced me to,
um,
try the diet for a month.
And that meant well,
it meant eating nothing but meat and
vegetables and that would beef chicken
and vegetables.
That's it.
No carbohydrates,
no nuts,
no nightshades,
no beans,
no dairy,
no chocolate,
no fruit,
no sugar.
Like unbelievably restrictive.
It's been a real pain because it's
really compromised my social life
because they're like,
who's going to invite you out?
Because so many people,
you know,
are,
um,
so much of what people do socially,
it revolves around eating.
And if you're really a royal pain in the
neck with when it comes to your dietary
proclivities,
then people are just not going to be
very happy about you.
Anyways.
I tried the Diet for a month and I lost
about seven pounds,
which I've,
and I quit snoring,
which,
which had been plaguing me to some
degree.
And so I thought that was pretty
interesting.
And,
um,
so I just stayed on it.
Then I lost,
I kept losing them about that much
weight per month.
So I went down from about 212 pounds to
my current weight,
which is about one 70,
which is about where it was when I was
in graduate school.
And so anyways,
this is a long answer to this question.
MMM.
Because of that,
all my clothing became tent like,
and I had to throw all of it away.
And so I got some new clothes in more
recently and including some very
colorful socks.
So I guess that's my,
uh,
what would you say?
I don't know what else to say about it,
that,
that I have these colorful socks and
they're,
they're kind of interesting and stylish.
And so that's what's with the socks.
So it's a complicated answer.
Hey.
So,
mmm.
Can you please take some questions
submitted via patron advance?
I did do that.
I did take questions.
I guess you might mean.
Do I answer that?
Will I answer some more of the questions
and I,
yeah,
I can do that.
I think what I would recommend everyone,
I mean we'll get better at this and I'm
going to keep doing it.
Um,
where'd it go here?
There are a lot.
Many of the questions that were
submitted on Patrion were very long and
I don't think that's going to work
because,
um,
it takes a long time to read the long
questions and
that means I can't answer very many of
them.
So one of the things I would say,
if you're going to submit a question on
Patrion,
at least for the time being,
you might,
might want to make them not more than
about maybe for la,
four or five lines long.
Cause I also have to scan through a lot
of questions to find out which ones not
only are worth answering because I think
many of them are worth answering.
But which ones I've got an answer at
hand for because I can't
sit here and think and produce dead air
for periods of time for this to work
properly.
So we'll figure this out as we go along.
So,
um,
Dr. Peterson,
in your lectures,
you speak a lot about toughening people
up as someone who went through college,
got a humanities degree,
bought completely into postmodern
ideology.
And until hearing your lectures couldn't
pawn pinpoint that feeling of
aimlessness,
hopelessness and the aversion to
responsibility,
where do you recommend they start?
I've particularly seen this inability to
be tough,
to negotiate and to bring up my inner
tyrant who is really just afraid.
Or You said it does bring out your inner
tyrant who is really just afraid it's
not going to get what it wants.
How do you begin to work with that?
Well,
that,
that's a good question.
And the next question is how can men
become more dangerous?
Well,
I can answer both of those at the same
time.
I would say for people who are too
agreeable,
the first thing that you need to know
what the first thing you need to figure
out is what is it that you want?
And
because if you don't want anything and
if you don't know what you want and you
don't know what your strategy is,
how are you ever going to be able to
conjure up the courage to stand for what
you believe in?
You don't believe in anything and you
don't have any arguments at hand.
And I mean,
that's part of the reason that we
developed the future authoring program
was so that people could not only figure
out what they wanted.
So to identify the goals in life,
which is identifying those goals as an
integrating force,
but also to articulate the arguments
that make them capable of defending
yourself.
You know,
like if I'm going to challenge you,
let's say you come to me and you say,
uh,
um,
I wanted to raise,
maybe it's taken you a lot of courage to
conjure to,
to,
to be able to step into the office of
your boss and say,
well I want to raise.
And he says,
well no,
we don't have any extra money at the
time.
And you say,
well okay.
And then you leave.
Well that's not a good negotiation.
If you want something,
the first thing you have to do is set up
options for yourself.
So if you really want to negotiate for a
raise,
let's say,
cause it,
we'll use this as an example.
The first thing you have to do is decide
whether or not you deserve to have a
race.
Because you can't just ask for one.
You have to make a case for it.
And so how do you know if you're in a
position to ask for a raise?
Well,
part of it is that you have options.
So I would say put your cv or your
resume in order and make it tight and
then look around to see what other other
employment options you have that you
would in fact take and see what your
market value is.
And because you have to have options,
you have to be able to say no one in
negotiation and then decide how much of
a raise you want and why it would be in
the person's best interest to offer you
the race,
make a case for it.
And one,
one of the reasons is,
look,
I've got this other job opportunity that
I'm pursuing and I like working here,
but I'm going to take this other
opportunity because it pays me more.
And you can't just say that if it's not
the case,
if it's not true,
because that's an absolutely foolish
negotiating strategy.
You have to have options,
you have to negotiate from a position of
strength.
And so you have to know what you want
and you have to have options.
And then you have to develop strategies
for communicating what it is that
you're,
that you're asking for and you,
you have to be forthright about that
and,
but you have to think through the
reasons because otherwise you won't have
enough courage to tolerate the conflict
that it might entail to,
to withstand the negotiation.
And I think if you're an agreeable type,
one way of,
of,
of fortifying yourself is to understand
how much misery and conflict you may be
storing up for yourself in the future if
you refuse or if you refuse to engage in
reasonable negotiation on your own
behalf in the present.
It's like,
so one of the ways I get myself to do,
to engage in conflict that I might not
have wanted to engage in.
And despite what you might think because
of what's happened to me over the next
six months,
I'm not a person who particularly enjoys
conflict.
I'm a person who knows that unless you
engage in a certain amount of conflict
to stand up for what you want,
that your life turns into hell.
And maybe the lives of people around you
turns into hell too.
And I'd rather have the damn conflict,
which I find quite stressful.
I'd rather have the conflict and allow
everything to degenerate around me.
And so,
okay,
so,
and then you say you bring out your
inner tyrant who is really just afraid.
It's not going to get what it wants.
Well,
you get what you negotiate for and if
you put yourself in a position of power
and you give yourself options,
then you will get what you most more
frequently than not,
you'll get what it is that you want,
but,
but not because you want it,
but because you have a variety of
options available to you that would
enable you to move forward more
effectively in life.
So,
okay,
let's see.
Note for Juliet.
Will this live stream be archived?
Yes,
it will be archived.
Our Youtube seems to do that
automatically.
So
is this chat really just patrons?
Yes.
It's just patrons.
I mean,
uh,
it's reasonable for the people who are
supporting the channel to have,
uh,
to,
to what it's reasonable for me to thank
the people that are supporting the
channel in a specific way.
I know that you guys,
because I,
I talked to a number of,
you are happy that your efforts are also
contributing to the fact that very many
people,
and it's about 8 million now by the way,
I'm very many people are able to watch
these lectures online and many people
are translating them and doing all of
that too.
So,
so the information that's available in
the lectures is spreading very rapidly
and the support that you've uh,
provided me with has not only
facilitated that and improve the
quality,
these offerings substantially,
but has also enabled me to start
thinking about what I might do in the
future that's more extensive.
And uh,
and so one of the things I thought I
would do is to thank the Patriot people
specifically for,
for devoting their resources to this
project.
And I doing the q and a's,
I'm going to do them once a month.
And um,
okay.
Yes,
it's just Patriot on people who are
going to be able to submit the cue the
questions.
Although everybody will be able to watch
them on Youtube because why not?
It's no,
no harm done there.
And it's nothing but benefit as far as I
can tell.
So I'm Benjamin.
Rude says Jordan,
why don't you use a dedicated microphone
and headphones?
There is a painful reverb slash echo
when you interview host people.
Yes,
I think I've taken care of that.
I've got a very good set of earbuds.
I've got new lighting.
Um,
I've got to though I have a very good
microphone even though I wasn't using it
very well.
And so I think I probably got that
solved and certainly the camera is much
better than the one before.
So,
um,
so let's see,
what else have we got to say here?
Okay.
One of the things also that I might
comment on it that's quite interesting
is that I've read a lot of the youtube
comments that accompany my video isn't,
you know,
I'm,
most of the time my experience is on
youtube that if you read the youtube
comments gives you a seeking feeling
about the potential future of humanity.
You know,
um,
people seem to use the opportunity
provided by anonymity to be some
strange,
frequently some strange combination of
arrogant and obnoxious,
but you know,
on,
on balance.
And I would say it's more than on
balance.
It's in the vast majority of cases the
comments that have been appended to my
youtube videos apart from the odd troll
and,
and the odd person making the sorts of
comments that no one should make,
the quality of the comments has been
very,
very high.
And so I'm very happy about that.
And maybe that's an accurate reflection
of the people that are,
are watching the information that is
provided by the videos.
It's rather difficult information and I
don't think it's particularly welcome to
those who only want to cause trouble.
So.
Okay.
Dr. Peterson,
I'm a psychology student.
What do you think is the role of
psychology in the selective
reconstruction of ethics?
Well,
I think that that's part of the reason
that I'm a great admirer of both Freud
and young and Rogers to that degree to
to some degree,
I know you don't and not,
I shouldn't only limit it to them
because I've learned a lot from reading
the great clinicians,
the great clinicians are attempting to
determine what the appropriate ethic is
that promotes both healthy lives and
healthy societies and they've made a
fair bit of progress.
You know,
and maybe this gives some credence to
Sam Harris's claim that you can derive
an ought from.
An is a,
certainly an is can inform an art,
although it certainly doesn't,
there's too many is,
is to,
to,
to derive arts with in,
in various,
I think that's the fundamental problem,
but it's certainly the case that one of
the things,
the pieces of wisdom that you can see
emerge across psychotherapists is that
um,
people are strengthened by voluntary
exposure to the things that they're
avoiding.
And that's a big deal because I think
that that's not much different than a
practical application of the lessons
that are embodied in Orthodox
represented rep that are represented in
an image and drama in hero mythology.
Because the hero is the person who goes
forth to voluntarily confront the
unknown and gained something as a
consequence and benefits the community
as a consequences.
Well,
and that is very little different than
the idea of exposure therapy and
psychotherapy.
And so that seems to me to be the base,
the core basis of a certain kind of
ethic is that human development is
facilitated by voluntary exploration,
confrontation and exploration of the
unknown.
And that looks something like it's all
right.
I don't know if she can precisely say
that that's an ought from an is,
but it's certainly 10 it's certainly
trending in that direction.
So psychologists can help us understand
the nature of human beings and by
understanding the nature of human
beings,
we may be able to better understand how
it is that human beings might optimally
behave.
So,
and that may also not merely be a
consequence of laying out the,
the vast array of empirical facts that's
associated with psychological
investigation.
It might also be a consequence of the
sorts of things that piaget talked
about,
which is the observation of how
societies right from the small societies
of childhood all the way up organize
themselves into coherent and functional
large scale units.
So,
okay,
how do you walk the line between being
too agreeable or disagreeable when in a
relationship,
not making it,
not making it boring or impossible to
work with the other person?
Well,
you,
you walk the line between being too
agreeable or disagreeable by self
reflection at by self reflection,
listening and negotiation.
So the self reflection is um,
continual self analysis about whether or
not you,
the relationship is fulfilling those
things that you need to be fulfilled in
to commit to it.
Um,
self reflection is continuing analysis
of whether you're acting in the other
person's best interest in a way that
facilitates your own interest in a
manner that makes the relationship
likely to last and maybe to extend out
beneficial beneficial consequences into
the broader community.
And then less by listening,
you get a chance to see how the other
person views the situation.
And by negotiating you enjoy,
you engage in joint problem solving and
the person will tell you often if you're
being a pushover,
you know,
you never tell me what you want to do it
and,
and then you get angry about it.
That that's often an indication that
you're being a pushover or,
or maybe you don't take enough during
sex or maybe you give,
you give too much or you don't take
enough during sex,
which is actually quite frustrating for
the other person.
And so it's self reflection,
listening and negotiation that that'll
help.
So that,
that's basically the,
uh,
short and straight forward answer to
that.
MMM.
Um,
let's see here.
Somebody said that Julian is cute.
Well,
I'll tell him that.
I'm sure he'll be happy to hear that.
I think he's cute too.
Although he's 25 year old man and he's
not necessarily all that thrilled when I
refer to him as cute.
He's actually quite tough and that I
think is actually tough plus cute.
That's a killer combination.
So
Elvin artists says,
I love your serious tone when answering
dumb questions.
Well,
thank you very much.
I appreciate the positive feedback.
It's how tall and my Dr. Peterson.
It depends on whether I'm sitting down
or standing up.
So at the moment I'm about three foot
six,
but generally speaking,
if I'm standing up,
I'm about six foot one.
So you could ask me some more questions
like that because it's getting late at
night.
And so those questions are really easy
to,
um,
to answer.
Someone says,
my father is dead.
Who Do I save from the whale?
Well,
that's easy.
You save your spiritual father from the
whale.
Um,
saunder behind her sis.
My feet lost weight.
Well,
possibly I haven't weighed them
independently of my body,
so,
but it is certainly possible.
Um,
Chinese culture mansplain says plus one
for Paleo.
You know,
I know a number of people who have
benefited substantially from a Paleo
Diet,
including,
uh,
a relative of mine who's a great genius
and whose life,
whose probably in better shape,
better shape.
Now that he's 60,
then he was,
when he was 45,
he made very radical dietary
transformations of approximately the
same sort that I've made in my keys in
extremely good physical shape and,
and doing very well mentally.
And so there is a lot more to the Diet
picture then we know and at least for
some people a heavy carbohydrate diet
seems to be absolutely catastrophic and
it's something I wouldn't have expected
because I'm one of those people who
regarded people who was,
who were hyper concerned with their diet
as,
as tending towards the unbearably
neurotic.
And I certainly learned my lesson about
that.
I no doubt in any group of people who
are hyper concerned about something,
there are people who are unnecessarily
concerned,
but there's definitely something going
on with our diets,
especially in North America because
everyone is overweight and far too many
people are depressed.
Um,
and I do think that it has something to
do.
I hesitate to say this,
but I do think that it has something to
do with eating too much green derived
carbohydrate,
specifically perhaps wheat and dairy.
Um,
there's there,
the situation may be more complicated
than that and it's not an area of
specific expertise for me,
so I'm hesitant to say anything more
about that.
So Robby Kelly says storing is from
being overweight,
sleep paralysis stops muscles in the
throat from keeping the fat away from
crushing windpipe.
Yeah.
Well,
I thought that too when I stopped
snoring.
But the thing is after I changed my diet
to basically a paleo diet,
I stopped snoring within a week.
It happened long before I lost enough
weight to make that,
that canonical reason.
So,
um,
let's see.
A commenter says,
Paleo meat plus vegetables did great
things for my depression,
weight and health in general.
Yes.
Well,
that,
that is,
uh,
um,
that is something that's characteristic
of many people's experience.
Loser lesser 55 says his snoring a bad
thing.
Uh,
well,
not if you enjoy it and not if you're
partner enjoys it.
But yes,
generally it's a bad thing because it
interferes with your sleep and anything
that interferes with your sleep is
generally a bad thing I get.
And it can devolve into sleep apnea
where you spend substantial periods of
time each night,
not breathing and uh,
that can cause very serious health
problems.
So,
um,
so yes,
it can be,
it generally snoring is a bad thing.
So what would you recommend to someone
who wants to try to be productive in
their free time but always gets sucked
in by video games and other
distractions?
While I would say,
define more carefully,
precisely what you mean by productive.
So get,
get a plan in order,
delineate the plan down to the level of
a daily routine.
Set up a daily routine,
using a calendar,
put in times that you're going to get
sucked in by video games and other
distractions because obviously you enjoy
that and then set yourself up so that
it's difficult to get access to those
things.
So
that's the answer to that question.
Okay.
More technical trouble here.
Hey,
because of that,
why in the world do you think it's doing
that?
I don't know.
So technological mysteries.
So,
um,
let's see here.
Congratulations on the socks,
the weight loss and better sleep.
Stay healthy.
We need you.
Well,
I'm doing my best.
I've had a lot of health problems over
the last,
well I guess to some degree over the
course of my entire life though I had a
very terrible time in December,
but I think I'm doing okay and um,
I don't think the health problems were a
consequence of all the political
controversy that I'd be in.
I just think they happened to Cole,
although one probably didn't really help
the other,
so,
all right.
Hey Julian.
Julian,
someone thinks that your cute.
Yeah,
someone thinks you're cute.
Hey,
you want to come and look at these
people and they can judge for
themselves.
Yeah,
sure.
Why not?
All right.
So this is Julian.
He's,
he's my son.
He's been helping me with all of the
technical issues that,
that I've been coming up against or the
last few months.
And so he wouldn't think I was cute if
you knew me.
Yeah,
well that's exactly right.
So I think actually if you know anyone,
you pretty much stopped thinking they're
cute.
So anyways,
so,
all right,
so let's see,
what else have we got here?
What type of therapy should I seek for
my social anxiety with so many different
options available?
Um,
I would say the most straight forward
form of therapy for something like
social anxiety is behavioral therapy and
the behavioral therapists are very
practical.
And so if it's relatively straight
forward,
social anxiety,
uh,
exposure therapy is very useful for that
sort of thing.
And sometimes social skills training,
if you don't feel that you have the,
the like the skill and wherewithal to
conduct yourself appropriately in a
social environment.
And some people aren't,
weren't socialized very well and so they
don't have those skills or they didn't,
they didn't get the opportunity to
practice.
I would say what's probably more
important is that you find a therapist
that you're comfortable with and who is
pushing you and helping you and
listening to you in a proper manner.
But behavioral therapy is very,
very effective for relatively straight
forward ils issues of anxiety and um,
and skill deficit,
let's say.
So.
Okay.
What else have we got here?
Do you think science is a different
domain then spirituality or religion and
therefore can't answer questions each
other's domain?
Yeah,
I do.
I do essentially believe that.
I think that science is pretty good at
laying out the landscape of empirical
facts and that the religious is the
domain that attempts to answer the
question,
how is it that we should act in the
world and there's overlap between the
two.
They can't be entirely separate domains,
but roughly speaking.
That's the distinction and I think the
reason is is that value free empirical
facts cannot.
You cannot derive values from a set of
value free empirical facts and empirical
facts by their nature are value free,
partly because the value is eradicated
from the empirical fact by the
scientific method.
That's actually what the scientific
method does.
Now.
It cannot do it completely because
scientists tend to concentrate on facts
that they assume are relevant to the
solution of a given problem.
They don't just randomly search for
facts and that's a good thing because
there's an infinite number of the
irrelevant facts to get separate them
completely.
I believe that the,
some domains are separate,
but that the scientific domain is
necessarily nested inside the
metaphysically religious domain.
And I believe that that domain is
isomorphic in some sense with the
Darwinian domain.
And that's the point I was trying to
make in the discussions I had with Sam
Harris.
I have a lecture about that,
Tom,
the name of which I don't precisely
remember unfortunately at the moment,
but it's a lecture on Darwinian versus
Newtonian approaches to the truth.
And I tried to delineate my,
my thoughts about that more particularly
in that video.
So
how old was I when everything you
understood started to come together?
Um,
I think that really started happening to
me,
started probably happening to me when I
was in my early twenties.
Um,
I think the most important realization I
had,
and I outlined this realization in my
book,
in the preface of my book maps,
maps of meaning that I realized at about
that age that almost everything I said
was a false set of one form or another.
It was either I was using language
instrumentally in order to win arguments
or to attain dominance or to indicate
that I was intelligent or to use it for
victory,
for,
for narrow local personal victory.
And I realized that when I was in my
early twenties and I started to cause a
voice in some sense of voice started
inside my head,
which I now regard as something
equivalent to the cricket in Pinocchio.
And it basically continued,
continually informed me that the things
I was saying weren't in some fundamental
sense weren't true.
And it was very disquieting because the
voice that was commenting on what I was
saying was making comments of that sort.
I wouldn't call him disparaging act,
our voices of voice.
It was more just a,
a matter of fact commentary.
But it was saying it about about 95% of
what I was saying.
And I thought,
well,
that's a strange conundrum because now I
don't know if I'm the voice that's
criticizing what I'm saying or if I'm
the thing that's saying what's being
criticized,
how do you figure that out?
But I decided that I would take a chance
and assumed that the part that was
suggesting that I wasn't saying things
truthfully was accurate.
And I started to practice only saying
things that that voice wouldn't object
to.
And I think that's also equivalent to
some degree to trying to say only those
things that make you strong instead of
weak or that make you,
that,
that do not fill you with a post speech
sense of shame and regret.
And I really think that was the
beginning of,
of all of this,
um,
about this.
It was at the same time though that I
was starting to work out to,
are starting to work on the problem that
I think is obsessed my,
my entire life,
which is what's the pathway between
nihilism and totalitarianism?
Is there,
is there a genuine pathway between those
two pathological extremes?
So,
and I think those things wove together.
I had a serious problem to solve and I
also tried to,
tried to begin to sort out my language
and really to learn how to work as well.
So,
and that was in my early twenties.
Um,
I mean I had lots of things to
straighten out in my life.
Many,
many things.
And I still have many things to
straighten out in my life,
but I think that's it.
So,
oh,
okay.
Okay.
But isn't the future authoring program
just praying?
Ah,
well,
you know,
whenever you ask a question and the
question is of the form,
is x equal to y?
The answer is always,
it depends on how you define x.
And it depends on how you define why and
it's not a copout.
I mean,
your question really means something
like,
are there important similarities between
what people conventionally described as
prayer and the meditative exercise that
you might undertake while doing the
future authoring?
And I would say yes,
there are important similarities.
I don't think it's reasonable to say
that they're the same because people
wouldn't automatically assume that they
were the same.
They're not obviously in the same
category.
But I would say that completing the
future authoring exercise is to a large
degree,
um,
putting into practice in a very
pragmatic way,
the ethical guidelines that were
outlined in the sermon on the mount.
Because what the sermon on the mount
basically says is something like aim at
the highest good that you can conceive
of and then concentrate on the day.
It's something like that.
And there's also a tremendous call to
truth in that sermon.
So yes.
Um,
Sam Dogan asks,
what is my favorite biblical story?
I don't know if I have a favorite.
I mean,
some of them I've analyzed more than
others.
I guess maybe that's wrong.
Maybe the story that,
that,
that
packs the most punch for unitive of,
of,
of conceptual effort
per unit of conceptual effort is the
story of Cain and Abel.
That is really quite a story.
I mean it's,
it's very,
very short and it's unbelievably punchy.
So,
so far that's the one that's been most
remarkably illuminating to me.
Now that's not it.
It's a tough,
tough question because I could say the
same thing about the story of Adam and
eve.
I mean when I understood like,
I mean,
gaining some of the insights that I've
had into these stories has really been a
mind altering experience.
So,
for example,
when I understood why it is in our,
at least I believe I understood why it
is that in the story of Adam and Eve,
that human beings accrued the knowledge
of good and evil,
that they were transformed into moral
agents when the scales fell from their
eyes and they realized they were naked.
That was unbelievably powerful
revelation for me.
And the revelation was,
for those of you who haven't heard me
talk about it,
that there's no difference between
recognizing that you're naked and
vulnerable and mortal and that you're
going to die so that you're a vulnerable
creature.
And,
and being able to take advantage of that
vulnerability as it's manifested in
yourself and other people.
So you cannot be evil without knowledge
of your own vulnerability and the
vulnerability of others.
And you can be evil as soon as you know
that,
because as soon as you understand that
vulnerability,
you understand how to exploit it.
So animals,
for example,
predatory animals don't exploit the
vulnerability of their,
of their prey.
I mean they killed them.
And so in that sense,
I suppose it's an exploitation,
but they don't take conscious advantage
of the prey.
Knowing what would hurt them as
individuals,
the milks,
they can't torture and they certainly
can't torture intensely and for long
periods of times,
like human beings scout now it requires
self consciousness.
And so it's the emergence of self
consciousness that gives people moral
agency because they,
they develop the capacity for evil at
that point and developing the capacity
for evil.
They offer also develop the capacity for
the opposite.
Which minimum is the,
the decision not to be as Google would
put it,
not to be any more evil than necessary.
Let's say.
So
Dr. Peterson,
am I in the Illuminati?
Huh?
Well,
if I wasn't in the Illuminati and I said
no,
that would just be proof that I was in
the Illuminati.
So I don't see any way I can answer that
question without obviously offering
proof that I am in the Illuminati.
So,
um,
I don't,
I'm in the Illuminati.
How's that?
That,
that might work out?
So
let's see.
Jordan,
Dr. Peterson,
will you visit Fredericton,
New Brunswick?
I have visited Fredericton.
I actually had quite a nice time there.
Um,
I,
I'm try,
I'm going to try to limit my travel to
about once every six weeks because I
have a bunch of other obligations that I
have to keep up with.
And so,
and at the moment,
Fredericton isn't on my travel schedule.
I am releasing a book in the early part
of 2018 it's called 12 rules for life,
an antidote to chaos and it's 12 essays
that I derived from a set of answers
that I gave on the website.
Cora,
to the question,
what are the most valuable things that
everyone should know?
What are the most valuable things that
I think I wrote 42 little rules there
and you can find
them@jordanbpeterson.com some,
um,
uh,
they're accompanied by photographic
images that one of my viewers has kindly
donated to the project.
People have been doing all sorts of Nice
and creative things for me,
helping me facilitate what I'm doing on
Youtube.
And they did that.
Um,
the reason I mentioned that is because I
presume that when that book is released
that I'll be going on a speaking tour
and it's possible that Fredericton would
be on that agenda,
but I don't know because none of that
has been formulated yet.
So,
um,
the book,
I'm happy with the book,
I've been writing it for about three
years and it's been quite thoroughly
edited and commented on by my editor at
Penguin Random House is publishing it in
Canada and fed a number of friends of
mine who are good authors and sometimes
excellent authors,
um,
review it.
And so,
um,
uh,
that should give me the opportunity to
do some more traveling and to talk about
the book.
So,
okay,
so let's say a Dr. Peterson,
how did the postmodernist so
successfully take over the education
system?
Man,
I should certainly knew,
wish I knew the answer to that dedicated
effort over three decades would do it.
But I would also say,
you know,
if people are continually funded by the
public purse for the political activity,
they can spend a tremendous amount of
time concentrating on it.
And so,
and when you also add to that the fact
that 80% of humanities papers,
uh,
Garner zero citations,
which means essentially that no one
reads them or if they do,
they don't do anything with them,
then you don't have to spend a lot of
time concentrating on what you're
writing because it tends to be a very
low quality,
at least judged by the standards of
attracting readership.
And so I would say we've devoted a
substantial proportion of the public
funding of higher education to the
production of precisely the kind of
ideological ideologically minded
activists who are aiming precisely at,
at,
at occupying positions of power
everywhere they possibly can and
transforming the social institutions
into,
into puppets of their particular form of
possession.
So,
okay.
Iq and wisdom.
What's the relationship between Iq and
wisdom?
I would say virtually no relationship
whatsoever.
There no evidence of any relationship.
So for example,
I,
wisdom seems to be something more like
the balance between,
uh,
a large set of,
of abilities and virtues.
And there is no evidence that I know of
that,
that people with higher iqs are,
are wiser than people without high iqs.
I don't,
I don't see any evidence for that.
So,
and I think it's partly because you can
be,
your,
your capacity to think can lead you into
very bad places just as well in some
sense as it can lead you into very good
places.
So it's a tool.
It's a very,
very powerful tool and it's a tool that
can be wielded for,
for better or for worse.
And even in relationship to your own
wellbeing,
have you seen many people who,
whose intelligence and rationality has
become nothing but the kind of critical
force that completely undermines their
capacity to live?
It makes them nihilistic and bitter and
resentful and,
and it's,
uh,
it's uh,
and proud as well because it's very
intelligent.
People tend to be very proud of their
intelligence,
which is also a mistake because they're
not the creators of that intelligence
and have no reason to take personal
credit for it.
So,
but wisdom,
whatever wisdom is,
doesn't seem to be related to in any
straight forward manner to street
intelligence.
So,
um,
someone says,
I made the mistake of using,
um,
psychedelic and recreational drugs to
access when I was young and I'm sorry I
missed,
I can't see the question right now.
So I'm going to have to regenerate it
for memory.
And the consequence of that I believe is
that my ability to think has become very
cloudy and uncertain.
And I don't know what to do about that.
I would say that you should probably go
talk to a psychologist or a psychiatrist
because there,
there may be things that could be done
to sharpen your thinking up again,
and maybe some of them perversely enough
might be pharmacological.
Perhaps,
you know,
what you're describing could be a
consequence of something like depression
or even post traumatic stress disorder.
Um,
so because the evidence on the longterm
use of,
of,
of psychedelic drugs for example,
isn't,
it doesn't indicate that in that overall
they produce negative health
consequences of the sort that you're
describing.
Now you might've had adulterated drugs,
you might've been one of those people.
And there do seem to be people like that
who are prone to negative consequences
for using various recreational drugs.
But I would say if you really think that
your cognitive ability has been
impaired,
you should probably go talk to a
psychologist or a psychiatrist and see
if you can do something about that.
Because sometimes,
for example,
antidepressants or drugs like
Wellbutrin,
which is also an antidepressant,
but a different kind can be very useful
in restoring mental clarity.
It's worth a shot.
You know,
you don't want to go through life like
that.
So,
okay.
Do I believe in the power of Lord Keck?
What do you think of the rise of belief
and need magic?
Well,
I don't think it's any different.
It's the use of archetypal imagery.
And I don't know if if,
I mean obviously archetypal imagery,
it has tremendous power.
And so when,
when right now people are obsessed with
archetypes of chaos and Kik is a
manifestation of an archetype of chaos
and,
and transformation because the frog is
a,
as a,
as a spirit of transformation.
I talked about that did an interview
with a great Russian Orthodox carver
named Jonathan Powell,
who's very knowledgeable about such
things.
And we did a,
uh,
a youtube video on the metaphysics of
pepe.
And so if you're interested in that,
you might want to take a look at that.
Um,
is there a universal female story
opposite to the hero myth?
Yeah,
I think there is.
I think it's beauty and the beast.
Um,
although I think that
the taming of the partner,
the taming of the wild partner as an as
a,
as a myth is applicable to men and
women.
There's an element of taming that goes
on in a relationship regardless of the
sex of the people who were involved in
the relationship.
So men,
team women and women take men.
Um,
I think the idea of taming and
civilizing men is more directly a part
of the fundamental archetype of the
feminine.
And I think that for a variety of
reasons,
but I think beauty and the beast might
be the canonical female heroes story.
So,
uh,
I would like to elaborate on that.
But what,
I'm starting to get tired and I don't
have the mental energy to do that.
I may do a video on beauty and the beast
though I'd like,
I would like to do that.
So,
um,
what do I think is the archetype whole
significance of the popularity of the
anti hero in American television?
Oh,
well that's,
that's easy.
I mean the,
the anti hero nature,
nature made the proposition that he said
that morality is cowardice.
No,
that's not exactly what he said.
What he,
what he said in a more elaborated for
him is that very frequently people are
afraid to do things and they're often
things that other people regard bad.
And because they don't want to admit to
themselves that the reason they won't do
those things that are regarded as bad is
because they're cowardly.
They pretended to that it's because
they're moral.
And so often conventional morality is a
consequence of conventional cowardice.
And the problem with conventional
cowardice is that it's not sufficient to
solve serious problems.
And so for example,
it's necessary for a man and perhaps for
a woman as well to become a bit of a
monster or even a lot of a monster in
order to move through life successfully.
And that doesn't mean precisely that you
have to act out being a monster,
but it means that you need to be able to
be a monster when the circumstances
demanded.
And so the reason that anti heroes like
Walter White,
for example,
are so popular in American culture is
because the criminal Walter White was by
no obvious,
was in no obvious way,
less moral than the conventional and
cowardly Walter White.
Now you might say he went from one
extreme to another,
which he did,
but it's also the case that in order to
expand past the domains of conventional
morality slash cowardice from the
Nietzschean perspective,
it's necessary to incorporate elements
of the shadow.
And that's in some sense what needs you
meant when he said that we need to go
beyond good and evil.
And it's certainly what you meant when
he said that it's necessary for someone
who wants to burst forth from the
potentially pathological combined
confines of their conventional persona
into the,
the journey towards individuation and,
and the development of the self was that
the shadow had to be incorporated.
And that means often in part,
the capacity for aggression,
uh,
the capacity for sexual expression,
the capacity to defy defy convention,
that capacity to take your own road.
And that's all predicated on the
development of an inner relationship
with the monster.
And it's the same idea that's expressed
in Harry Potter.
Harry Potter is actually able to combat
voldemort who's essentially Satan for
all intents and purposes because he has
a pace of evil,
lodged firmly within him.
And it's also what makes him a,
uh,
redeeming rule breaker.
Right?
So,
so the anti hero is the shadow,
roughly speaking.
And the shadow is the thing that the
persona needs to incorporate to become
the hero.
So
South Fresno says,
I preached a sermon and use some of your
cane enables stuff.
Well,
that's good.
I wouldn't say that it's,
my cane enables stuff though much as I'd
like to take credit for it.
Um,
but I'm happy to hear that.
And uh,
um,
I hope it worked well and,
and that there were people at your
sermon because otherwise that would be a
problem.
So,
um,
Jordan,
what's your favorite mean?
Made a view?
Well,
I don't know.
Um,
I don't know if I've developed a
favorite.
Um,
let me think about that for a minute.
I find the fact that they're being made
of great amusement,
I think it's absurd.
It's absolutely absurd and ridiculous
and I can't believe that it's happening.
So,
um,
I know that that's not much of an answer
to your question,
but,
um,
I find the whole category,
I don't know what to say about it.
It's surreal.
It's a surreal phenomenon.
And,
uh,
the association that has emerged between
me and,
and kermit the frog and pepe,
I also find that that's,
that's,
that was actually the most
market form of synchronicity that I,
I've ever seen manifest itself.
So that was really something quite
remarkable and amazing.
And I talk about that also with Jonathan
Patio on the,
in the metaphysics of pepe.
So
turned off again.
Yeah,
I turned it back on.
It seems to turn off on a relatively
regular basis.
So there must be something.
There must be some setting that we just
don't understand that any of you have a
Canon camera and you use it for video
broadcasting and it shuts off now and
then,
and you know why you could,
uh,
put that in the comment section.
I'm sure we'll figure it out,
but it does seem to be a regular
occurrence.
So,
all right,
so I'm going to sign out here pretty
quick because I'm starting to wear out
and I don't want to say anything
pathologically idiotic for public
consumption and that could happen and
that would be a bad thing.
So,
okay,
so let's see.
I'll ask answer one more question.
MMM.
The Canon cameras in the tea range,
go to sleep at Canon.
Cameras in the tea range.
Go to sleep.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Hey,
that's from Louis Guillermo Martinez
Pinzon.
And if I remember correctly,
please correct me if I'm wrong.
I believe that that is the delightful
gentleman from Mexico who's produced
the,
uh,
excellent graphic intro that I use on my
videos and he's produced another one for
me,
which I'm going to be using on my
youtube interviews.
So thank you very much,
Luis,
and,
and I will,
or Louie and I will check that out.
That's,
that's a good,
that's good hint.
Thank you very much.
What are my personal spiritual practices
and rituals?
Um,
the simpsons.
Yeah,
I'm absolutely addicted to the simpsons.
I think I've watched every single
episode of the simpsons at least five
times.
Generally what I do is I start with
episode one and I go through all of
them.
And that takes about a year or maybe a
year and a half.
And then I started at the beginning and
again,
and I go through them again.
And I also watched the trailer park
boys.
I'm very embarrassed to state to say
that,
but I,
I've also quite addicted to the trailer
park boys and that's outside on.
I don't know what to say about that,
but,
um,
I,
I think that bubbles is one of the most
remarkable comedic characters that
Canadian comics have ever developed.
And I think the same thing about ricky,
I really think that show is a profane
and,
and distasteful work of genius and it's
a guilty pleasure.
So I guess those are my spiritual
practice watching the simpsons in the
trailer park boys.
I should also tell you,
because this is a funny story and
because my son happens to be sitting
here with me and he can tell you that
this is the truth.
When my kids were little,
we didn't have a television and the only
television show I ever let them watch
was the simpsons.
Yes,
exactly.
And so when they were really little,
I used to cover up their eyes when itchy
and scratchy came on because I thought
that was a bit too much.
But,
um,
I thought that the simpsons was a very
honest satirical show and that it was
teaching them the proper,
the proper rules of life and they didn't
seem to turn out too badly.
And they have really good senses of
humor.
So,
um,
so it seems to have worked on all
Simpson Diet.
That's not the ritual I recommend for
children.
I didn't take them to church,
but I,
I had them watch the simpsons on regular
basis and probably I should be hauled
off in front of the child,
you know,
child welfare people for that and
admitting it.
And that's why I need to stop because
I'll tell you other things that I've
done and I'll get myself in trouble.
So.
All right.
So,
oh,
and Louie Guillermo Martinez has been
zone says also when no one presses any
buttons.
I see.
Okay.
So it is set to automatically shut off
because it assumes that no one is doing
anything.
Do you know Louis,
what I can do to stop it from shutting
off because I don't want to get up in
the middle of a broadcast and like push
a button.
So,
so much,
much appreciated.
So,
okay.
I think I'm going to stop guys.
Um,
I appreciate that.
I appreciate the support very much and
I'm doing my best to put it to the best
of all possible uses.
One thing I couldn't tell you is that
you know that I'm doing this series on
the Bible.
You may know that or may not.
It's going to start I believe May 16th
but possibly May 23rd and I'm going to
go through the Bible from beginning to
end describing the psychological
significance of the stories.
But another thing that I've got involved
in recently,
and this is in,
it's in its early stages of development,
but I met a group of of moderate Muslim
intellectuals in Toronto a couple of
times now and they're planning a
reformist movement,
a reformist Islam movement that will be
grounded in Canada.
And I hope to be involved in out in some
integral manner,
partly as a consequence of doing youtube
videos and podcast interviews on the
topic of Islam and on how it,
how it's more extremist elements might
be properly Moto Mod,
your ma moderate it.
And so you know,
that's a big deal and who knows if
that'll go anywhere.
But that's definitely something that I
want to devote my attention towards
because it seems like an extraordinarily
important topic.
And so with any luck,
I'll be able to concentrate my attention
on elucidating the psychological
significance of the biblical stories
from beginning to end.
And also engage in a dialogue with
intelligent and careful and thoughtful
moderate Muslims about how we might
bridge the gap between our two
civilizations in a manner that would be
productive.
And so that's part of what I'm,
that's what I'm aiming out utilizing the
resources that you,
people are partly providing me with as
well as continuing to develop the
youtube channel and,
and the,
the biblical lectures will be taped by
the same people who'd be doing my
lectures.
And so,
um,
that's part of,
that's part of the upcoming plan over
the next couple of years.
So I would say,
and that might be enough if I could do
those two things extraordinarily well or
even well,
hopefully I could do them
extraordinarily well,
but if I could devote my efforts to
doing that credibly,
that would be,
that would be really worth,
that would be something really worth
doing.
So thank you all and thank you for
putting up with the technical glitches
and all of that.
And I'll,
I'll get better at this as I go.
Uh,
you know how it is when you first do
something.
It's okay if you're a fool,
as long as you're not any more of a fool
than you have to be,
and you get better at things by doing
them somewhat badly to begin with.
So anyways,
thanks very much.
I'll see some of you again in a month
and,
uh,
um,
over now and thanks to Julian very much
for helping me sort this out and set it
up good night.
Hm.